>> Sean: BREAKING NEWS AS WE
BEGIN TONIGHT.
THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT
BREAKING MOMS
BREAKING AOMS
BREAKING AMOS
BREAKING AMOUNTS OH, MY
BREAKING NMOUNTS OH, MY
BREAKING NEWUNTS OH, MY
BREAKING NEWS,TS OH, MY
BREAKING NEWS, T OH, MY
BREAKING NEWS, THEH, MY
BREAKING NEWS, THE A MY
BREAKING NEWS, THE ATTY
BREAKING NEWS, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BARR JUST APPOINTED THE
U.S. ATTORNEY IN CONNECTICUT TO
INVESTIGATE THE WITCH-HUNT INTO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, THIS IS HUGE
NEWS, A COLOSSAL STEP FORWARD
FOR EQUAL JUSTICE, EQUAL
APPLICATION UNDER OUR LAWS, A
BIG PART OF WHAT'S COMING.
IF YOU'RE COUNTING, THIS IS NOW
THE THIRD INVESTIGATION INTO THE
DEEP STATE TAKING PLACE IN
BARR'S DOJ.
ADD SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
AND WHOEVER
AND HHOEVER
AND HOOEVER
AND HOOVEER
AND HOOVERR
AND HOOVER IS INVESTIGATING THE
LEAKS IN UTAH.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, OPERATION
CROSSFIRE HURRICANE IS, AS WE'VE
BEEN CALLING IT, OPERATION BOOM
BOOMERANG.
SENATOR ABOUT LINDSEY GRAHAM
ASKED THE ATTORNEY GENERAL ABOUT
THE MUELLER REPORT, ABOUT WHAT
HE VIEWED AS IMPORTANT.
WE TOLD YOU LAST WEEK, ACT TWO,
THE CURTAIN IS ABOUT TO GO UP.
TONIGHT THE CURTAIN'S UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU SHARE MY CONCERNS
ABOUT THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, HOW IT WAS
OPENED, WHY IT WAS OPENED?
>> YES.
>> YOU SHARE MY CONCERNS THAT
THE PROFESSIONAL -- LACK OF
PROFESSIONALISM IN THE CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION IS SOMETHING
WE SHOULD ALL LOOK AT?
>> YES.
>> DO YOU EXPECT TO CHANGE YOUR
MIND ABOUT THE BOTTOM LINE
CONCLUSIONS OF THE MUELLER
REPORT?
>> NO.
>> DO YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT'S
CAMPAIGN IN 2016 WAS THOROUGHLY
LOOKED AT IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THEY COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIANS?
>> YES.
>> AND THE ANSWER IS, NO,
ACCORDING TO BOB MUELLER?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HE COULDN'T DECIDE ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION.
YOU DID.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> DO YOU FEEL GOOD ABOUT YOUR
DECISION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Sean: WHILE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BARR SEARCHES FOR TRUTH
AND JUSTICE AND IS FULFILLING
WHAT HE SAID HE WOULD DO,
TONIGHT HYSTERIA SPREADING IN
EVERY CORNER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AS WE NOW INCH CLOSER TO
THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE NOISE ON THE LEFT, IT IS
GETTING LOUDER AND LOUDER AND
LOUDER, BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE,
IT'S ONLY NOISE.
NOTHING MORE.
IT'S NOT BASED ON ANY FACTS, ANY
TRUTH, ANY REALITY.
WE NOW HAVE HAD OVER THE COURSE
OF TWO YEARS, COUNT THEM, FOUR
SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS THAT
HAVE CLEARED PRESIDENT TRUMP,
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, OF ANY TYPE
OF COLLUSION OR OBSTRUCTION.
DEMOCRATS, IT'S ONLY NOISE.
THEY CAN'T LET THEIR OWN LIES
AND CONSPIRACY THEORIES GO.
WHILE THE LEFT CONTINUES TO PUSH
THEIR HOAX, WE'VE BEEN
UNCOVERING THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
ONLY WE HAVE EVIDENCE.
IN THE END FACTS SPEAK LOUDER
THAN HYSTERIA.
TONIGHT THE FACTS ARE CASTING A
DAMNING SHADOW ON THE DISGRACED
FIRED FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY, NOW BEING CALLED OUT
PUBLICLY FOR -- BY HIS FORMER
COLLEAGUE OF ALL PEOPLE ROD
ROSENSTEIN IN A MAJOR WAY
TONIGHT.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> I DO NOT BLAME THE FORMER
DIRECTOR FOR BEING ANGRY.
I WOULD BE TOO IF I WERE IN HIS
SHOES.
BUT NOW THE FORMER DIRECTOR
SEEMS TO BE ACTING AS A PARTISAN
PUNDIT, SELLING BOOKS, EARNING
SPEAKING FEES WHILE SPECULATING
ABOUT THE STRENGTH OF MY
CHARACTER AND THE FATE OF MY
IMMORTAL SOUL.
I KID YOU NOT.
THAT IS DISAPPOINTING.
>> Sean: ROSENSTEIN UNLOADING,
SAYING HE BROKE, MEANING COMEY,
LINES THAT SHOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN CROSSED.
ROD ROSENSTEIN IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT TO SLAM THE FORMER
DISGRACED FBI DIRECTOR.
COMEY ABUSED HIS POWER.
THE EVIDENCE AGAINST HIM IS
MOUNTING.
HERE IS WHAT WE NOW KNOW.
OCTOBER 21st, 2016, THEN FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY SIGNED OFF
ON THE FIRST OF WHAT BECAME FOUR
REQUESTS AGAINST TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE CARTER PAGE, DENYING
HIM HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT,
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY OFFERING A
BACKDOOR INTO ALL THINGS THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HILLARY CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DOSSIER, ACCORDING TO
MEMOS, THE BULK OF INFORMATION
WAS THE PREDICATE FOR THOSE FISA
APPLICATIONS.
THEY WERE UNFAIRFIED, PAID FOR
BY HILLARY, SOMEBODY THAT HATES
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S JUST RAW INTELLIGENCE.
THAT WAS THE BASIS FOR A
WARRANT?
NOT ONE, BUT FOUR?
AND COMEY SIGNED THE FIRST ONE.
IT SAYS ON TOP OF THE WARRANT,
VERIFIED.
THE COURT WAS NOT INFORMED
CLINTON PAID FOR THIS.
EVEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
SUGGESTING RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
INSTEAD JAMES COMEY SWORE THAT
THE INFORMATION HE PROVIDED IN
THAT APPLICATION WAS TRUE AND
CORRECT.
THE APPLICATION ITSELF MARK
VERIFIED AT THE VERY TOP, BUT
THE DOSSIER WAS NEVER VERIFIED,
FRANKLY UNVERIFIABLE BECAUSE
STEELE DOESN'T STAND BY IT.
DURING AN OINTERROGATORY THAT'S
WHEN WE LEARNED THAT TRUTH.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS TRUE, BUT
HE WAS UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE HATED THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP, AND WILLING TO
DO ANYTHING TO TAKE HIM DOWN.
DOJ OFFICIAL BRUCE ORR WARNED
THE FBI, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ABOUT STEELE'S
HYPERPARTISAN CONDUCT, AND
STEELE'S TIES TO THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN WELL BEFORE THE OCTOBER
FISA REQUEST.
THE WARNING CAME IN AUGUST OF
2016 BEFORE THE OCTOBER 2016
FISA APPLICATION.
LAST WEEK WE LEARNED ALSO A
HIGH-RANKING STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL, HER
OFFICIAL AHER
OFFICIAL ALSR
OFFICIAL ALSO ISSUED A DIRECT
WARNING ABOUT STEELE 10 DAYS
BEFORE THE FISA REQUEST, PASSED
ON THE RED FLAGS ABOUT STEELE'S
ELECTION ETHICS, THE VALIDITY OF
HIS WORK, AND SENT IT TO THE FBI
AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THEY STILL WENT FORWARD AND USED
THAT INFORMATION ANYWAY.
NOW SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM IS
WORKING TO DECLASSIFY A
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENT HE'S SAYING
TONIGHT WILL PROVE THE FBI
ABSOLUTELY POSITIVELY KNEW THAT
STEELE'S WORK WAS FULL OF LIES
AND GARBAGE AND HILLARY PAID FOR
IT.
BY THE WAY, A LIE BY OMISSION IN
THE CASE OF THE FISA COURT
ABUSE.
THEY LITERALLY CONSPIRED TO
COMMIT FRAUD ON A COURT, THEY
HATED DONALD TRUMP THAT MUCH.
WE KNOW GRASSLEY AND JOHNSON
ISSUED SEPARATE DOCUMENT
REQUESTS FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AND FBI IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE WHAT COMEY KNEW ABOUT
STEELE WHEN HE SIGNED OFF ON THE
WARRANT TO SPY UPON AN AMERICAN
AND AN OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE.
IT'S NOT LOOKING GOOD FOR
MR. SUPER PATRIOT JIM COMEY.
AND FISA ABUSE IS JUST ONE PART
OF WHAT IS LAWLESS BEHAVIOR AND
ABUSE OF POWER.
CONGRESSMAN RATCLIFFE IS CALLING
FOR AN INVESTIGATION INTO JAMES
COMEY TONIGHT.
>> JIM IS PROUD OF HIMSELF, BUT
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND HIS
INSUBORDINATE, AND MANY OF US
BELIEVE HE SHOULD BE UNDER
INVESTIGATION FOR THE ESPIONAGE
ACT, FOR RECORDING HIS
CONVERSATION WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN THE OVAL OFFICE AND
INTENTIONALLY LEAKING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO START THIS
INVESTIGATION.
SO, YOU KNOW, MARIA, AS YOU
KNOW, AS A FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR, I'VE WORKED WITH
HUNDREDS OF FBI AGENTS, AND OVER
THE LAST TWO WORDS THEY HAVEN'T
USED WORDS LIKE PROUD TO
DESCRIBE JAMES COMEY, BUT USED
WORDS LIKE EMBARRASSED AND
ASHAMED.
>> Sean: WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
A SINGLE PREMIER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENT IN THE WORLD, SINGLE BEST
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES IN THE
WORLD, NOT THE 99.9%, BUT THE
UPPER ECHELON, THEY'RE THE ONES
THAT ABUSED THEIR POWER.
THE JIM COMEY OF THE WORLD,
SELF-RIGHT, SUPER PATRIOT, HE
CAN DO NO WRONG.
WE WARNED HIM MANY TIMES.
HE HAS THE RIGHT TO REMAIN
SILENT.
HE'S NOT LISTENING TO ME.
DOESN'T MATTER HOW DRAMATIC
OP-EDS HE WRITES FOR "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" OR LONG INFOMERCIALS
HE DOES WITH ANDERSON COOPER
OVER AT FAKE NEWS CNN, HE'LL
NEVER ESCAPE SIMPLE TRUTH AND
FACTS.
HE WAS A TERRIBLE FBI DIRECTOR.
HE ABUSED HIS POWER.
IT'S A GOOD THING THE PRESIDENT
FIRED HIM.
WE KNOW NOW HE WAS INVOLVED IN
RIGGING THE INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY CLINTON.
HE ENGAGED IN A WITCH-HUNT
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE ANOINT A PARTISAN CORRUPT
GROUP OF BUREAUCRATS INTO HIS
INNER CIRCLE, ALMOST ALL OF
WHICH WERE FIRED OR DEMOTED, AND
WILLFULLY MISLED AND COMMITTED A
CRIME ON THE FISA COURT TO SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WE KNOW HE LEAKED SENSITIVE
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS, AGAINST
THE LAW, BECAUSE HE WAS MAD THAT
HE GOT FIRED, AND LEAKED IT TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WITH THE
PURPOSE OF GETTING A SPECIAL
COUNSEL APPOINTED.
NOW HE'S IN SERIOUS LEGAL
JEOPARDY.
JAMES COMEY, TICKTOCK.
WITH THE HELP OF SARAH CARTER,
JOHN SOLOMON, SO MANY OTHERS ON
THIS PROGRAM, WE'VE ALWAYS
WORKED TO HOLD POWERFUL
UNELECTED GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
ACCOUNTABLE.
THE LEFT IS MORE INTERESTED IN
SCORING CHEAP POLITICAL POINTS,
DIVIDING THE COUNTRY, AND PUCKER
CONSPIRACY THEORIES WITH NO
EVIDENCE.
IN THE DEMOCRATIC-CONTROLLED
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES, THEY
HAVE PEOPLE TRYING TO WEAPONIZE
THEIR COMMITTEES.
WHY?
TO HARASS AND ORDER AND PROLONG
A SERIES OF ENDLESS WITCH-HUNTS
INTO THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
NOW SENATOR GRAHAM HAS
DOCUMENTED THEIR UNPRECEDENTED
BEHAVIOR.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY JUST WANTED AN OUTCOME.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW YOU GET
TRUMP.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU TRICK
THE FISA COURT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU
INFILTRATE THE CAMPAIGN.
THE GOAL IS TO STOP TRUMP AND
THE RULES DON'T MATTER.
THIS IS A VERY DANGEROUS TIME IN
AMERICAN HISTORY WHERE THE MEDIA
AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTS
AN OUTCOME AGAINST TRUMP, NO
MATTER WHAT THE RULES ARE.
>> Sean: DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY WANT TO DESTROY THIS
PRESIDENT.
THEY DIDN'T WANT HIM ELECTED.
THEY HAD A FAVORITE CANDIDATE.
THEY RIGGED HER INVESTIGATION.
THE EVIDENCE IS OVERWHELMING.
IT IS INCONTROVERTIBLE.
SHE HAD TOP-SECRET INFORMATION
ON A SERVER, WHICH WAS ILLEGAL,
AND TRIED TO COVER UP THE
EVIDENCE.
SHE BUSTED UP HER DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS AND REMOVED SIM CARDS TO
DESTROY EVIDENCE.
THE UNDERLYING CRIME?
ESPIONAGE ACT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL PROVIDED
ACCESS TO ALL BUT TWO FULL AND
SEVEN PARTIAL LINES OF THE
MUELLER REPORT.
THEY'RE TOO LAZY TO GO LOOK AT
IT.
THIS WAS GRAND JURY INFORMATION.
MADLER'S COMMITTEE HOLDING HIM
IN CONTEMPT, DEMANDING THAT HE
BE HANDCUFFED BY THE SERGEANT AT
ARMS BECAUSE HE'S OBEYING THE
LAWS OF THE LAND.
YOU CANNOT REVEAL GRAND JURY
MATERIAL.
THAT IS THE LAW OF THE LAND.
AT LEAST ONE PERSON UNDERSTANDS
IT.
THAT WOULD BE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
BECAUSE BARR REFUSED TO BREAK
THE LAW, AND REVEAL GRAND JURY
INFORMATION, CONGRESSMAN NADLER
IS HOLDING HIM IN CONTEMPT,
TALKING ABOUT PUTTING HIM IN
HANDCUFFS, CALLING THE
HANDCUFFS. CALLING THE
FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA MOB ARE
DECLARING WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS.
WE'VE BEEN THERE FOR THE LONGEST
TIME BECAUSE OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ABUSE POWER, BUT OF COURSE
THEY'VE BEEN PUSHING CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND LIES.
OF COURSE YOU GOT THE INTEL
CHAIRMAN.
YES, THE COWARDLY SCHIFF,
DOWNRIGHT APPEAR POLECKIIC,
LOSING HIS MIND, BECAUSE THE
ONLY PERSON CAUGHT ON TAPE
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS IS
HIM AS HE GOT CAUGHT UP IN A
HOAX.
OH, DO YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE ON
DONALD TRUMP?
YEAH, WE HAVE EVIDENCE.
WHAT IS THE EVIDENCE?
NAKED PICTURES OF TRUMP.
DID VLADIMIR PUTIN SEE IT?
VLADIMIR, OF COURSE HE SEES IT.
>>
.>
.REALLY?
ERIC HOLDER WAS HELD IN
CONTEMPT, AND IN THAT CASE OBAMA
DID INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
SOMETHING THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION DONALD
TRUMP NEVER DID.
HE TOLD EVERYBODY IN THE WHITE
HOUSE TO COOPERATE.
THEY HANDED OVER 1.5 MILLION
DOCUMENTS AND ANSWERED MUELLER'S
QUESTIONS, AND STILL NO
COLLUSION.
FOR THE FOURTH TIME WE GOT THAT
CONCLUSION.
ANYWAY, TAKE A LOOK AT THE
COWARDLY SCHIFF.
>> THEY SEE ME TURNED OVER
ALMOST THE ENTIRE MUELLER REPORT
UNREDACTED.
THEY'RE SAYING THEY'RE PREVENTED
BY LAW FROM GIVING OVER THIS
GRAND JURY INFORMATION.
SO WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE HERE?
>> THERE ARE CATEGORICAL
DIFFERENCES.
FIRST, THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
PROVIDED THOUSANDS OF DOCUMENTS
AS YOU JUST HEARD TO THE
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS.
AND YES, IT MADE SPECIFIC CLAIMS
OF PRIVILEGE.
HERE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAS DECIDED TO SAY A BLANKET NO.
NO TO ANY KIND OF OVERSIGHT
WHATSOEVER.
NO WITNESSES, NO DOCUMENTS, NO
NOTHING.
>> Sean: NO WITNESSES, NO
DOCUMENTS, NO NOTHING.
YET AGAIN THE COWARDLY SCHIFF IS
LYING.
HE'S A LIAR.
MR. SCHIFF, COME ON THIS PROGRAM
ONE FULL HOUR, YOU AND ME.
I'VE GOT A DOSSIER ON YOU.
IT'S CALLED YOUR OWN WORDS.
THEN COME ON MY RADIO SHOW FOR
THREE FULL HOURS.
YOU CAN BRING NADLER WITH YOU
JUST FOR KICKS.
THE FULL MUELLER REPORT HAS BEEN
RELEASED, THE AG HAS TESTIFIED
BEFORE CONGRESS, AND ADAM SCHIFF
IS LYING AGAIN.
HE'S LOSING IT AT THIS POINT.
THIS KIND OF FARFETCHED HYSTERIA
FROM THE LEFT IS NOT GOING
UNCHECKED.
AS PER USUAL, PRESIDENT TRUMP
RIGHTLY NOW IS FIGHTING BACK
AFTER FOUR EXONERATIONS, CALLING
THE DEMOCRATS FAKE
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS NARRATIVE
PATHETICALLY UNTRUE.
THAT IS TRUE.
THE PRESIDENT IS ALSO CALLING
OUT THE CURRENT FBI DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER RAY ACCUSING HIM OF
PROTECTING THE SAME GANG WHO
TRIED TO OVERTHROW THE DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
DEPLORABLES THAT CLING TO GUNS,
BIBLES, AND RELIGION.
THAT'S US.
SO FAR I DON'T SEE THE DIRECTOR
DOING A DARN THING TO CLEAN UP
THE UPPER ECHELON OF THIS FBI.
THAT'S HIS JOB.
FOR THE 99% OF FBI SPECIAL
AGENTS THAT PUT THEIR LIVES AT
RISK FOR US EVERY SINGLE DAY,
YOU OWE IT TO THEM TO GET THIS
DEPARTMENT, THIS PREMIER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY RIGHT WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT HAS HE DONE TO HOLD COMEY
ACCOUNTABLE?
NOTHING.
WHAT ABOUT BAKER?
IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO DO YOUR
JOB.
THE FORMER HIGHEST RANKING
EMPLOYEES IN HIS BUREAU
COMMITTED REAL CRIMES, AND YET
NO SIGNS THAT HE SEEMS TO CARE
ONE BIT TO BRING THEM TO
JUSTICE, OR WORKING TO PREVENT
THIS ABUSE OF POWER
HYPERPARTISAN CONDUCT FROM EVER,
EVER HAPPENING AGAIN.
BUT IN THE COMING MONTHS,